you
yeah school lunches are promoting
childhood obesity but in a indirect way
they said whatever goes on in school
sets an example for kids about what's
supposed to be and if the kids are being
fed chicken fingers and salty foods and
sweet things and bodeman and are have a
lot of sweet and salty snacks around
that they're eating they think that's
appropriate and that's the school saying
this is what you're supposed to be
eating and that's why I think it's so
important to have school lunches that
serve healthy food and I've been to
schools that do and they're very
impressive guess what the kids eat it
seemed perfectly happy
yeah there are two things that have to
happen one is the government has to set
rules for what kids can and cannot eat
in schools so that you know the rules
are in place and then you need people in
the schools who really care about
wanting to do a good job of feeding kids
and think it's really important for kids
eat healthfully in schools where that's
happening the food is good the kids are
eating it everybody's happy